it's been nearly 20 years since the
murder of world famous fashion designer
Gianni Versace the style icon was gunned
down on the front steps of his Miami
Beach mansion but there are still some
unanswered questions in a preview of
tomorrow's 48 hours Richard Schlesinger
takes us back to the crime scene to
investigate Versace's killer who also
took the lives of four other people do
you remember where you were when you
heard that
Versace had been murdered oh I remember
profoundly I opened up my computer and
it flashed before me that Jennifer Sun
she had been murdered I was stunned it's
a real wow factor Project Runway's Tim
Gunn says Versace's murder at the peak
of his career was shocking news to
everyone especially in the fashion world
Charlie Rose interviewed Gianni Versace
in 1994 why should anybody care about
fashion even the people who say they
don't care they care I promise you on
July 15 1997 Versace was at his lavish
miami beach retreat Casa kazarina at the
time Carlos Noriega was a lieutenant
with the Miami Beach Police Department
that particular morning Gianni Versace
decided to go over to News Cafe and it
was on his return home approaching the
door he was was shot and killed police
were lucky they got a break from
Versace's friend
Lazaro Quinn Tana who was at the mansion
he heard the shots go get him and
followed the gunman
I yelled why did you do this why did you
do this he stops right across here and
that's when he's pointing the gun at me
the shooter went into this parking
garage Lazaro found a policeman so
that's when I told the officer I said
he's in there go get him Lazaro never
saw the gunman's face but he did see his
clothes inside the garage police
discovered clothes that matched the
description Lazaro gave them they were
next to a stolen pickup truck and inside
were documents the gunman had vanished
but now police had a name andrew cunanan
we consider andrew cunanan to be armed
and to be extremely dangerous and as it
turned out cunanan was already the focus
of a nationwide manhunt michael williams
knew him andrew was very pretentious
loud you know always had to be the
center of the party Cunanan was on the
FBI's ten most wanted list tied to four
other murders before versace the first
two were his friends we have what we
typically call a spree killer former FBI
profiler
Mary Ellen O'Toole this wasn't a
haphazard crime mr. Prasad she was
targeted mr. Schlesinger joins us at the
table so we just heard your piece he
knew this first two victims we ever it
was it ever determined if he knew Gianni
Versace there are so many questions
about this case still 20 years on there
are theories that he had to have known
Versace because it was just otherwise
it'd just be too random yeah some of the
police think he did some of
Versace's friends think he did but other
people very close to Versace said they
never met they never crossed paths
Richard you interviewed one of andrew
cunanan other victims or another 48
hours piece what did you learn about him
he was an amazing guy we did we were
doing a story on gauged the military
back in the 90s when Don't Ask Don't
Tell started and we interviewed this guy
Jeff trail that you see him here
remarkable guy Annapolis graduate Gulf
War vet just terrific guy very
courageous what was strange was when we
were doing this story we were talking to
one of his friends and his friend told
me that at the same time we had met him
he had just met Andrew Cunanan what's
the status of the Versace empire today
it's being run by Donatella his sister
one of the interesting things when we
were talking to Tim Gunn about Versace's
legacy is that designers still refer to
him and and and find inspiration in him
which I thought you know given clearly
as you can tell I'm not much of a
fashion maven but I would thought that
they would have gone with more modern
people but there are very young
miners who were still influenced by
Versalles geminal from seminal mine 20
years later though he has a very
distinct he had a very distinct look
that does not change richard good to see
you good to see you you can see Richards
full report it's called murder by design
tomorrow night at 10:00 9:00 central
right here on CBS